there's people right now who are like
sitting there going you know I'm putting
away money to move to Montana or
California back to Jersey in New York
and you're always a little scared and
these stories I'm telling you right now
about Colorado 183 that was the first
time I was around in New York City yeah
it was the first time I was ever in
Miami
I was another state I myself I had a
roommate when he was struggling just
like me it's like I couldn't I might be
late with the rent there do you
understand me like the way insane right
you're saying take the chance move out
no no no boy is amazing like walking
home in those days and November and in
Colorado if you lived in those places at
night oh you smell his wood party oh
yeah you can hear it crack like that and
you can hear it it's cold but not really
it's real quiet and serene and I would
be walking to that parking lot like
walking and doing what a 21 year old
doing skate on it and I never know wow
what do you [ __ ] are really
missing and even though I'm by myself
look at what I'm doing by myself I agree
I agree that's the most important thing
that people always scared of them they
don't know if they're gonna that
satisfaction of having that closet with
that fan you're even what you want
you're driving lifts yep whatever you
trying to pull it together just to prove
to yourself that you can and there's one
night where you'll be there with
crackers you have the computer I'm
watching Game of Thrones and you'll have
crackers and you have a can of sausages
and a doctor coke one and you'll sit
there and you'll go how [ __ ] lucky am
i yeah I'm in Sacramento home and well
as you live in my dream I might be broke
before tonight oh good yeah I'm good I'm
not home I'm out of that bomb
environment Amana that that that's what
that that that part of my life always
was I was ashamed how then they caught
me Robin I planned the jewelry heist
they already knew I was burglarized in
these places I was in deep they knew I
didn't know
acted like I didn't do coke that was my
cover doesn't even that every cokeheads
cover no no at this time I was doing
that like oh yeah at this time I was
doing it to steal got it like the finger
can never be torn to me why would he
steal he don't even do coke look at the
size of reason he let's wait so it's a
bag every [ __ ] bag he does push-ups
in between us I like an idiot
I played the pothead got it you follow
me in the right the pothead never and
they would smell coke around me and then
they talk and we go back into that house
Nick played God awesome to come back I
would come out of the back room with a
kilo of coke there we go we got a pigeon
there we go pilot to Bombardier I give
them away right away with those guys you
just put them on a hook and just got one
guy eventually on a throne men they just
kind of working and see what's going on
the woman in the house who his room man
is I knew the room rent think I worked
at a [ __ ] golf court that went away
from the date time and this guy skied
the apartments wide open and the coke is
a bet in the bedroom somewhere in that
closet in the hallway then and I got 5
minutes but there's a [ __ ] sliding
window in the living room like when I
come into place I'm gonna open up the
sliding window I'm gonna leave it open
just so I have the option to walk out
the sliding window if they come to the
front door ok so I would always open up
my pass out before I even go for the
loop I go for the loot I find the loot
I'd lock the door how it was I got the
back door I look pop boom I walk out the
back door I'm a believer look at birds
oh my god it's a silver belly blue chip
from català did you learn that door
trick the hard way like that seems like
something you might have to learn when
he could trap somewhere I was really
good at it because all the condos were
made the same from building a the
building ok and they were all the same
cut if I could break into one though I
can break into all my buddy was an
engineer and he made the clips to bust
into all the doors but my cookie listen
I'm not the smartest in the world so
once I because new people live upstairs
not talking about drugs all the time and
I don't really befriend them I just hear
them chatter at cardi's how much blow
they do so I watch them when
again I go into the [ __ ] front door
lock the door the lights are out I go in
the back but again it's snow enough so I
get to the back door and I slide open
the sliding door and I [ __ ] go to the
back and boom it has to blow I see the
lights pull up I closed the door boom oh
I locked the front door I got in the
[ __ ] back as I'm running out
boom I left the screen door up to one
with the Flies or the Flies no comment
and I landed right in the [ __ ] grass
I just closed the sliding door and they
were right there and I [ __ ] ran it
wasn't fresh No thank God that's what
saved me yeah it was old snow so I
didn't leave I just ran I ran into like
the water I ran across and I went to
this Crestwood where I used to work and
I saw my friend call and I gave him the
coke and I changed shirts and then he
gave me a ride to my house like nothing
happened and the next day there was
chitter chatter something around my
house where I was it'll blow that's
terrible
did you help him look first oh yeah you
should have seen you have to put up
posters yeah your dog waiting and that
[ __ ] crazy Lee I was nineteen years
old doing this kind of she just crashed
like a crate [ __ ] [ __ ] is making
love the thing it's not like you're in
Jersey where you had friends and you
could come up with schemes you were out
there by aunt Ellen place it's like oh
my god getting stoned and thinking of
weird criminal [ __ ] you could do okay so
now I go back to [ __ ] New Jersey oh
my end up living in a playground
I don't do blow from Stanford back to
Jersey I go back to Jersey
I [ __ ] up completely I live in Jersey
285 and I moved to bold I got a little
loop put away but but I was a [ __ ]
dirty fear I got 10 G's in the back I
got Experian in my pocket so Sunday
night I'm on the Pro Street warm is one
of those cookie houses when they make
this is Paul's cookies Heather let the
window open it's something that's their
fault it's undone you think there's
money in that hon
you're stealing mrs. Paul's cookie boy
those cookies
No Name no means fuck-all no names you
understand me I [ __ ] jumped in there
there wasn't a register I just plugged
the register and press open clips $9,000
my browsing so people are me yeah oh you
know I was always such a bad beef I used
to unplug the register and take it with
me because sometimes I was getting on it
I could even open the [ __ ] register
so I don't have to go to the car but at
the back door leave the trunk opening go
out there with the whole register and
take it to go I did not know about to
take a big dose but where do you hide
the register on your way out
I always [ __ ] put in the trunk of a
car go running through the mall with the
registering your hey no no would be
running to the moral register the
business will be locked
it'd be like in the business I go in
there you know okay
they turn the electricity off they turn
they turn the electricity off so you
can't open up the register so you gotta
unplug the [ __ ] pick it up and you
gotta bring clients sometimes you gotta
bring cutters with you with gloves I
always like gloves on because you might
have to cut it because they hide the
plug underneath like they build a really
sorry oh no I'm taking I must have taken
15 registers of my day and then I knew
nothing about it but the do name Tompa
Nessie got brushes so he probably you
had a missing I was a Westie one-eyed
West the guy used to get me John I was
like 18 - case choice and he used to
tell me how to steal and [ __ ]
he's a tell me how to take chanting
groan toenail in prisons is [ __ ] I mean
this dude was the best I loved at all
the answers John Cage enjoying a job
that's a big job to believe yeah that's
a big job how to do once a guy that paid
me to just stand by the wall what do you
do I can't stand by the wall ten bucks
an hour just stand there from 6 to 20
but you got a document it's not easy
worse [ __ ] hilarious
the guy's name weed mr. Bochy I used to
hire me like three nights a week to
stand by the brick wall don't move [ __ ]
I'll bring you a sandwich
and the right here or left that seems
like you look perfect yeah Tommy one of
these days I'm gonna get your job 12:15
an hour sweeping a roof you know saying
that used to be the job you want it come
on mr. t get me a job sweeping the roof
12:15 alone I believe just sweep all day
just wait the roof every day eight hours
they just make the same roof it's going
to be alright it's gonna be alright and
then what and then you watch
everything's billiards nobody sleeps the
roof it's a Miller show job Lynn no
that's what it's called the sweeping the
roof I need a job sleep in the roof yeah
Eleanor you knew that right yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy sleep in the roof